c'è una celebre frase di albert einstein
cioè io non so diceva einstein con quali
armi si combatterà la terza guerra
mondiale ma sono sicuro che la quarta si
farà usando bastoni e pietre c'era una
previsione quasi apocalittica di un
mondo distrutto che torna all'età della
pietra ed invero l'onu che nasce nel
1945 quindi all'indomani della seconda
guerra mondiale proprio vuole evitare
cioè il ripetersi di una esperienza come
quelle due guerra che chiamati nel
preambolo della carta istitutiva
dell'onu un flagello hanno condotto
l'umanità a indicibili sofferenze per
ben due volte
infatti dato nuovo l'innovazione
profonda sul piano giuridico di questa
organizzazione universale che comprenda
tutti gli stati del mondo è quella di
vietare non sono la guerra che il
passaggio era lecita gli stacchi
potevano ricorrere alla guerra per
risolvere le proprie liti per affermare
i propri interessi invece con la carta
dell'onu la guerra divenga illeciti e
vietata come evitato qualunque uso
perfino minaccia della forza armata
naturalmente
il diritto generale ma nelle relazioni
internazionali ancor più non basta porre
dia gli vieti occorrono delle garanzie
delle sanzioni nel sistema dell'onu
viene individuato un organo il consiglio
di sicurezza al quale è demandata la
responsabilità di e il mantenimento
della pace quindi questo organo formato
da 15 stati fra i quali cinque sono
membri permanenti sono gli stati uniti e
regno unito la cina la francia e la
russia
ebbene quest'organo ha il compito e il
potere di intervenire con mezzi
economici commerciali diplomatici o
persino con misure di carattere militare
qualora uno stato commette un atto di
aggressione o comunque è vero violi la
pace o minacce la pace internazionale in
un certo senso il consiglio di sicurezza
e la forza pubblica e la pubblica
autorità alla quale gli stati possono
ricorrere nel momento in cui uno stato
venga meno al divieto di appunto
astenersi dalla forza nel sistema che il
nono peraltro il perseguimento della
pace avviene anche operando sulle cause
delle tensioni internazionali del mio
sistema nella carta che l'uomo infatti
l'organizzazione si propone anche di
promuovere lo sviluppo economico e
commerciale di realizzare il principio
di autodeterminazione dei popoli di
sviluppare la protezione internazionale
dei diritti umani e direi che su questi
piani l'uomo ha conseguito dei risultati
alcuni veramente di alto valore il
principio di autodeterminazione dei
popoli è valso a
svolgere un'azione significativa sin
dagli anni sessanta del secolo scorso
per la decolonizzazione che ha portato
all'indipendenza vari popoli che erano
soggetti a dominazioni coloniali
anche sul piano della cooperazione
commerciale anche se mi pagano ancora
lontani e vero gli obiettivi di sviluppo
sostenibile
promossi dall uomo però dei passi avanti
certo ci sono sul piano dei diritti
umani materia nella quale gli stati in
passato non erano tenuti a render conto
a nessuno in questa materia invece si
sono creati non sono convenzioni e norme
per la tutela dei diritti umani mag
edile garanzia specie in organismi
regionali quindi non solo mio nonno
penso alla corte europea dei diritti
dell'uomo nella quale l'individuo può
fare causa al proprio scatto davanti a
un giudice internazionale cose
impensabili solo è vero quarto il
decennio fa
ora se c'è un punto che è però è quello
forse più critico è deludente
dell'azione dell'onu
e proprio il mantenimento della pace
perché l'esperienza ci presenta
purtroppo una pluralità di casi
drammatici non solo di sporadiche
violazioni della pace ma di vere e
proprie guerre di aggressione
motivate vario modo
motivate come per esempio hanno fatto i
paesi della nato il 99 nella guerra
contro la repubblica federale di
jugoslavia con l'intento di evitare o
far cessare una grave crisi umanitaria
nel kossovo
lo stesso argomento
respinto allora da vari paesi
la russia la cina gran parte dei paesi
del terzo mondo e poi utilizzato già
proprio dalla russia per il suo
intervento militare con l'ucraina a
difesa delle popolazioni del donbass
penso anche alla difesa preventiva da
legittima difesa e una anche nel diritto
penale italiano e una causa di non
punibilità nessuno commette un reato se
lo fa chiede una certa condotta per
difendere appunto un attacco a un
proprio diritto
anche nel diritto internazionale è
consentito usare la forza
i miei confronti di un paese aggressore
finché non intervenga il consiglio di
sicurezza
però questo concetto si è molto dilatato
anzitutto perché il consiglio di
sicurezza ma come vedremo fra un attimo
purtroppo spesso impotente davanti alle
crisi più grave per cui una risposta in
legittima difesa rischia di trasformarsi
in una guerra da un punto di vista
giuridico la guerra del vietnam e così
lacerante nel secolo scorso e vero è
stata giustificata come un intervengo in
legittima difesa degli stati uniti anni
fa è saputo del vietnam del sud ma si è
addirittura che ho ridato un concetto di
difesa o testino guerra preventiva
collego prima bush nel 2002
base a questa dottrina sarebbe lecito
l'uso della forza armata non per
respingere un attacco armato ma per
prevenire il pericolo di un attacco
armato con mezzi appunto armi di
distruzione di massa
anche nella crisi
come la guerra che l'ucraina la russia
ha fatto perno su questo concetto
affermando un proprio diritto di
intervenire per difendersi
preventivamente da minacce che la nato
permettetemi di fare notare che
normalmente c'è una contrapposizione per
la quale vengono usati gli stessi
argomenti ma solo a proprio vantaggio
nel senso cioè che la russia che
legava a pugliola difesa preventiva un
intervento umanitario poi l'applica da
parte dei paesi occidentali che lo hanno
applicato dico purtroppo anche l'italia
per italia è gravissimo perché non c'è
solo una violazione della carta dell'onu
ma del precetto dell'articolo 11 della
costituzione nella quale ha proprio
l'italia ripudia la guerra come
strumento di offesa alla libertà degli
altri popoli e come mezzo di risoluzione
delle controversie
ebbene è vero gli stessi paesi che di
volta in volta hanno cercato di
giustificarsi per intel intende
umanitario o la guerra preventiva hanno
poi accusato gli altri per un gioco
delle parti nel quale forse l'unica cosa
che a mio parere si può dedurre che
questi non sono tesi giuridiche sono
argomenti politici usati al gusto non
delfini per giustificare la propria
condotta
ma al di là del e può purtroppo varie
esperienze drammatiche
del passato o del presente
perché l'uomo non funziona perché il
consiglio di sicurezza non riesce ad
agente della sua funzione di gendarme
internazionale direi anzitutto perché
nel consiglio di sicurezza è stata
fissata la regola per la quale di norma
un membro permanente ognuno di questi
può impedire col suo voto contrario
l'adozione di una risoluzione si che in
ogni crisi internazionale nelle quali si
è coinvolto una grande potenza e
normalmente una grande potenza è
coinvolta sempre o in prima persona o in
guerre per procura e consiglio di
sicurezza è rischia di essere
paralizzato dal veto di un membro
permanente e spesso lo è in secondo
luogo il consiglio di sicurezza avrebbe
dovuto avere a sua disposizione un
esercito navi militari mezzi militari
strumenti logistici
questi strumenti questo apparato
militare doveva essere messo a
disposizione del consiglio di sicurezza
in base ad accordi con gli stati membri
il consiglio avrebbe potuto quindi in
ogni momento ad horas intervenire
militarmente se ce ne fossero scarpe le
esigenze se non che questi accordi non
sono stati mai conclusi il consiglio di
sicurezza non ha mai avuto a sua
disposizione un esercito mezzi militari
e quindi pur nelle volte in cui ha
trovato un proprio consenso una propria
maggioranza richiesta per di kiir ha
dovuto far ricorso a operazioni di
peacekeeping autorizzazioni a skateo
organizzazioni strumenti che non sempre
funzionano nella maniera migliore che
talvolta possono anche dare luogo a
gabusi da parte gli scacchi in greco che
penso al caso della libia del 2011
ora cosa si può pensare di fare di
modificare il sistema certo si potrebbe
pensare di farlo ma sarebbe io credo
solo un pio desiderio perché una formale
revisione della carta delle regole
richiederebbe ancora una volta il
consenso di tutti e cinque membri
permanenti e improbabile quindi che
questi possano mai rinunciare ai propri
privilegi
si può credo forse per correre con
maggiore realismo qualche altra strada
come quella per esempio di creare degli
organi sussidiari che consente un e qui
non ci sarebbe bisogno di nessuna
riforma della carta dell'onu che
consentano per esempio all'assemblea
generale di avere quasi una seconda
camera c'è un organo sia pure consultivo
che rappresentino i governi ma i
parlamenti nazionali quindi nelle loro
articolazioni politiche la società degli
scatti pò club dei singoli stati
potrebbe far sentire la sua voce
potrebbe anche essere approfondita la
collaborazione con organizzazioni non
governative con altri attori
internazionali che pure sono importanti
non sono stata lì ma anno direi un ruolo
internazionale da svolgere
si potrebbe anche qui non ci sarebbe
bisogno di cambiare nulla
valorizzare al massimo il ruolo che il
consiglio di sicurezza non come gendarme
ma come per così dire conciliatore il
consiglio di sicurezza può alla luce
della carta fare delle raccomandazioni
svolgere un'opera conciliativa fra le
parti di una controversia e lo può fare
senza diritto di veto dello stato
coinvolto nella controversia nella crisi
che l'ucraina la russia non potrebbe
votare e chiaro che qui si deve puntare
a una soluzione amichevole accettata
dalle parti a un compromesso che può
rappresentare a livello internazionale
un risultato importante direi quasi
nobile perché può consentire di tenere
conto dei vari interessi in gioco che le
ragioni di tutto e comunque può essere
la via migliore per riportare l'uomo al
suo compito principale che mantenne
della pace non promuovere guerra
cosa può dirsi alla luce di queste
osservazioni il diritto può salvare
l'umanità può fare qualcosa beta solo
direi di notti di rick è uno strumento
viene male nelle mani degli stati ma non
solo degli stati intesi come i governi
delle opinioni pubbliche dei parlamenti
che dovrebbero vigilare meglio sulla
politica estera dei propri governi
vedere se è appropriato mandare armi o
non mandarle longa è vero seguire
pedissequamente le opinioni di un
governo il quale pedissequamente segue
gli ordini di un altro governo
insomma una vita democratica
a livello internazionale ea livello
nazionale quella si potrebbe credo
ridare fiato vidal autorevolezza anche a
loro e in questo senso il diritto né le
mani di persone di governi di scacchi
che in buona fede
di rally costruttori di pace
ecco potrebbe allora veramente il
diritto credo salvare l'umanità